eine versammlung in miami im us
bundesstaat florida aus haiti stammende
einwanderer treffen sich für eine
kundgebung gegen präsident donald trump
dieser soll bei einem treffen mit
parlamentariern haiti und einige andere
länder höflich übersetzt als tracks
löcher bezeichnet haben
verbunden mit der frage warum die usa an
menschen von dort aufnehmen sollten
ein mann von den vereinigten staaten von
amerika spricht bedeutet das wort
vereinigt ja wohl alle eine person
alleine kann sich nicht vereinigen
wenn sie meint präsident der vereinigten
staaten von amerika sind müssen sie der
präsident für alle sein
sie müssen auf der seite von allen
stehen nicht nur auf einer seite in
miami leben viele einwanderer aus dem
verarmten karibikstaat einen stadtteil
nennt sich sogar selbst klein haiti
haitianer haben sich hier ihre
infrastruktur geschaffen in restaurants
bieten sie ihre eigene küche an
es macht mich traurig und es ist
wirklich unglücklich dass der
us-präsident der alle lieben akzeptieren
sollte so eine aussage trifft
das ist eine schande aber das schlimmste
ist deshalb präsident haiti nicht kennt
wir sind ein offenherziges voll trump
hat inzwischen dementiert von tracks
löchern gesprochen zu haben
ein bei der sitzung anwesend der
us-senator bestätigt die wortwahl indes
schwamm habe die formulierung sogar
wiederholt benutzt